hi hi hi so I loved the film it made me
wanna like God cinema and party and was
it as much fun to film as it looked
absolutely I think so definitely we had
a blast I mean there's a lot of party
scenes but also just like it was a small
group of people working on this film so
we all got to really bond awesome and
Zach Jason Stewart Gager a three month
master class like giving him his bike
and taking a few tricks of the trade
have you got the DJing book now and will
you be hosting a club night anytime soon
um I I probably won't be deejaying or
hosting any club things I'm pretty busy
with work but I did get a crash course
on DJing from a great a great teacher
Jason Stewart them jeans is this DJ name
yeah um and yeah I figured out what I
was doing up there Zach her name is
Emily
you had insane chemistry especially when
you're in Vegas and do you believe that
couple who raves together stays together
oh my god I love that phrase um I think
a couple that has fun together stays
together
yeah yes mmm and that maps the scene
where that character sees Emily's
character for the first time I thought
was really powerful and kind of stumbled
up love at first sight that's what I got
from it and how important was that scene
in the movie and do you all as a bleep
believe in love at first sight the scene
was really important in the movie it's
kind of the first moment where zach is
kind of put on his heels and and thrown
a little bit off out of the world that
you know he's always been a part of
which is his guys and promoting and
hustling and this is kind of the first
time he he realizes there might be
something more that he wants we actually
played with how crazy and magical we
wanted it to be and I think we settled
on somewhere right in the middle
um do you guys believe in love them
first night don't it's that bad to say
that okay don't be sorry
list infant this defense I I believe in
lust and foresight yeah yeah Betsy yeah
yeah love is a little something you got
to work at well I'll know when I find it
yeah my my not LaVon annoying
you had love for dogs and animals at
first sight I feel you on that yes
hundreds don't agree and so Emily I
would be well nervous dancing on camera
like it's literally my worst nightmare
did you practice a lot in the mirror
before the night before maybe filming
and where do you get your confidence
from um god no I didn't practice in the
mirror before
um I think you just kind of have to feel
the music and have fun with it and the
importance is having that confidence and
sort of forgetting about you know cheesy
phrase that everyone says like dance
like no one's watching is actually
really came into play with this um and I
think my confidence just comes from like
self-acceptance and having great parents
and people who love me they want to like
bring in a choreographer and I remember
sitting with you and remember yeah we
were like we got this you were like you
were like let's just go do it yeah 99
that it was an awesome she's like yeah
no choreographer we're good and Emily
wasn't even supposed to dance in that
pool party yeah that wasn't I don't that
thing that was like that was a laugh
that was on the day I was like oh by the
way Emily would you mind like dancing
for the words of the student and
temporary it's Friday more pretty much
so that's amazing
I'll practice I'll watch it again impact
assessment for the minitor party and and
Zach in a film someone in the movie says
you're not even a real person until
you're 27 and you turn 27 last year so
do you agree with that and how do you
feel you're chained since your younger
years um wow I don't know if I'm a vet
statements accurate cuz I know a real
person yeah you're pretty real I'm
getting close here close uh oh my god -
yeah um I think I I don't know my life's
been such a whirlwind I think um I think
as long as I'm learning and growing and
continuing you know on my path that yeah
I uh I'm figuring out who I am I feel
great and I feel I feel real I feel
alive so I'm nothing instrument any
sense
it's cool yeah I think that when you
started the movie - and then towards the
end of it I felt like you when I first
met you to where you were in the movie I
I did feel like you had congealed into
like a true real healthy human being I
think now more than ever not thank you
max I think now more than ever I have a
true sense of of who I am and what I
aspire to do and and so that is that's a
good feeling and I am 27 so that's yeah
yeah cool and Emily and you're pretty
much kind of like the only girl in the
movie the main girl like but did the
guys and treat you like one of the boys
by the end of filming or and did they
play any pranks on set um you know it's
funny there were kind of two different
storylines because there's two different
sides to Cole's character so I didn't
get to spend as much time with the boys
but when we did we definitely had a good
time and I heard lots of stories about
the wild things that happen when it was
just the boys days so I heard but I
heard about that but you all talk
together in that hair and live together
for a week that was cool
we got yeah we got together for a
weekend weekend's we got a house in the
valley and Bryan ops general slumber
parties yeah one summer don't worry
about it
oh yeah the whole experience that was
was very I mean it was improvisational
it was real because we spent so much
time together and each of these guys was
actually very method in their process so
um it was it was really fun to work with
these guys we did become best friends
and in fact you play so many different
characters is there one character out of
your whole of your back catalogue but
you would ever like to play again or
revisit ooh um I mean I love to revisit
call I'm excited to to revisit um Teddy
because I'm doing neighbors to I'm
excited about that one find your future
by emulating someone else's [ __ ]
points you in the face if you don't get
50 more people on that guest list
immediately if you have a dream and it's
made up of everything that makes you you
money deceit self obsession in the
never-ending pursuit of [ __ ] that's the
ticket
this is my future I don't know what I'm
doing